happiness is a really tricky question
wanting to be happy is in some way
saying like I want to eat a meal so big
I'm never hungry again it's a misnomer I
think that the idea inhibits or prevents
a lot of entrepreneurs from continuing
down the path is that they are like I'm
not happy I prefer to use the word Joy
but I feel like Joy is a lot more
internal and you can be in the thick of
it and working on your auto detailing
business on the 37th door of that day
and you have a little tick mark and you
know you got to get to 100 and you had
the last 36 slammed in your face but
like you can be joyful if you reframe
the joy around the person you are
becoming by doing the hard work